Tina wrote in hey David how fractured is
the Democratic Party right now this
might shock some people I don't think
the Democratic Party is that fractured I
think that there are cracks that are
being blown out of proportion so let me
give you an example and we've talked
about this before a lot of people like
to present the Russia situation as a
civil war among the left where you have
people who believe that the Russia
investigation is nothing and people who
believe the Russia investigation is
everything and it's gonna take down
Trump that's a totally caricatured
version of it most of the left basically
thinks the the Russia situation is
sketchy and it needs to be fully
investigated but meanwhile let's keep
thinking about 2018 and 2020 and issues
and our platform right I think the vast
majority of the left and the Democratic
Party believes that but it's very up
profitable it's very compelling
titillating in some way to make it seem
as though the left is ripping itself
apart over the Russia investigation and
it's just not true another example the
anti sjw Left versus the sjw left it's
not as big of an issue as it's being
made out to be yes there are
unproductive elements of the left that
have taken identity politics and
language policing to an extreme that is
totally unproductive it's not a big part
of the left and the truth is it's not
playing a major role in the discourse
around policy it's a very loud minority
it's a minority that gets a lot of
criticism from the classical liberals
and the alt-right and whatever who try
to trump it up but I don't actually
think that there's that big of a crack
or split and it's probably not even a
50/50 split oh 90/10 split and yet I
will attend is allowed ten that's it I
don't even think it's ten percent I
think it's even smaller than that but
they are very very loud yeah whatever
issues are there I mean uh economic are
dualism general split between the
progressive Bernie Sanders type
Democrats and the neoliberal corporate
Clinton type Democrats that's more real
you see overlap with those who think
that there's some validity behind the
Russia investigation like those who
supported Bernie in the primaries may
think that he was robbed yeah and
therefore this Russian stuff is a
distraction and there's people who
support Hillary Clinton who think that
she would have won had Russia not
interfered that's more important to them
but the thing is most so among those who
connect the Russia story to either
Bernie or Hillary winning in the DNC
there is definitely a split but I
believe that that's just a small
percentage of the democratic party at
large and the left at large like I voted
for Bernie in the primary and I voted
for Hillary Clinton in the general
election and I don't believe that the
Trump Russia story in any way influences
how good of a candidate Bernie was and
how good of a candidate Hillary Clinton
was it's just a totally different thing
it has nothing to do with that
specifically so I I think it's important
not to overstate the split or fracturing
of the Democratic Party because it's
counterproductive if you believe that
the party is super fractured then you
were also probably going to focus on the
wrong issues in thinking about how the
framing and positioning should be for
should be set up for 2018 or 2020 so
don't be tricked into thinking that
there's this major fracture and the
thing is even if the party is fractured
that's not necessarily a bad thing when
it comes to making gains for the next
election cycles arguably like
Republicans in 2010 they had a split
between the more mainstream Republicans
in the Tea Party wing and yet they still
took control of the house in 2010 ranked
or by the time 2014 came around you had
people like Ted Cruz who are a lot more
out there and vocal and shut the
government down and yet still they won
the Senate that year so that's a more
still be productive when there's a
fraction your party fracturing can also
be called diversity of opinions yes and
if those diversity if that diversity of
opinion is not used to exclude people
from quote the left then arguably it's a
good thing because there are more entry
ways of appeal to people to become part
of the Democratic Party or the left and
again I'm not I've never been a Democrat
but I
I'm staunchly on the left and I think
that there are lots of different sets of
ideas that still qualify as being on the
left and some illiberal ones which we've
pointed out as well which i think should
not be part of the left yeah it works as
long as you can keep it cordial and and
think of it as everyone being under the
same umbrella with the same goals
although sometimes we see that it that's
not sometimes it doesn't happen and
that's not good right and when you start
actually getting people who are going to
end up voting for well people on the on
the far far far left that have no chance
of winning and are arguably destructive
or just voting for Republicans that's
when it becomes damaging we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about Larry Nasser we will talk
about the plan for next week and many
many other important things get access
to the bonus show by signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership or at
patreon.com slash david pakman show